Amna Muhammad has come here to shop for
years living in umur man in Sudan's
capital Kum she normally can find most
of what she needs here but for months
she hasn't been able to afford
food there is an increase every month
the prices of meat poultry vegetables
all have become very expensive since the
War Began the cost are too high because
our income is limited and there are no
salaries what used to be enough for us
to sustain ourselves in a day now we
need to double
that market prices have been increasing
since the start of the war between the
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces last April the UN says the cost
of an average basket of food has
increased by 88% since the conflict
began Traders say one of the reasons
behind the price Rises is difficulties
in getting
Goods some things we have here are
imported there's been an increase in the
price of foreign currency so the the
cost of food commodities has also
increased and especially because we also
have to add a small profit margin so
customers that come in buy less and less
because their money hasn't increased in
value or amount the World Bank forecasts
inflation to reach nearly 160% this year
the value of the Sudanese pound currency
has sunk fuel costs have increased too
the ongoing fighting and destruction of
factories means that Goods now take
longer to make it to Market
there are medines that now come from one
state when in the past it came from
another there are also others that
factory owners had to relocate so they
include the cost of relocation on the
price of
medicines with the conflict showing no
sign of ending prices are expected to
rise even further with more Sudanese
fearing they'll be unable to afford
their basic needs hea Morgan Al jaaz
Kum make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
zero